so let's keep talking about labor as a
factor of production and particularly
when I think about the supply curve of
Labor so when you're thinking about the
supply or the demand curve for a leat
labor when you think about quantity you
could just view that as hours worked in
a certain time period hours worked and
then for the price of Labor you could
just do that as wages and we've already
thought about what the demand curve for
labor would look like at high wages not
a lot of folks will want to use that
labor it's going to be so expensive they
might not even be able to afford it and
then as wages come down more people will
generally what will demand that labor
and so they will want more hours to for
folks to work and so this would be our
demand curve or we could call this our
labor demand curve now what about the
labor supply curve what do you think
that's going to look like well not a
trick question
when wages are low a lot of folks might
say hey I have other things to do with
my time but then as wages get higher and
higher
they might trade off those other things
they're the doing those other things in
some ways has a higher opportunity cost
it gets more expensive and so they might
trade off those other things for working
and so they might collectively work more
and more hours and so as wages go up
generally speaking hours worked goes up
so this is a fairly classic looking
labor labor supply curve and this
dynamic that I just talked about where
people are trying to trade off whether
they work or whether they do other
things
this is typically referred to as the
labor leisure leisure trade-off now in
everyday language when you use the word
leisure it's usually referred to your
relaxing or spending time with friends
or enjoying yourself in some ways but
when people talk about the labor leisure
trade-off in economics they're really
talking about labor or anything that is
not Labor so leisure would include
sleeping or eating or using the restroom
all of
would be included so it really should be
called the labor not labor trade-off but
I guess that doesn't that doesn't sound
as good is labor leisure trade-off and
so what you really see happening here is
is wages are higher and higher people
are willing to trade off leisure I'll
put that in quotes for labor now the
effect that we often talk about why that
is and a lot of ways it's common sense
that's the substitution effect
substitution effect as wages go higher
you could view the opportunity cost of
leisure gets more and more expensive and
if anything gets more expensive you try
to substitute it with other things in
this case you could substitute it with
more labor by just working more now
there is an interesting dynamic that
some people talk about which is the
income effect which is the income effect
and the income effect is as your wages
go up you tend to want to buy or demand
more of everything and you could view
leisure as a good that you as a worker
might want so there might be dynamic
that if income gets above a certain
level that you actually might not want
to work more that you actually might
want more leisure because you have more
than enough to supply all of your needs
and so if you wanted to imagine what a
labor supply curve would look like if
you if you could imagine the income
effect kicking in at higher wages it
actually could look something like this
at low wages it could look very similar
to what we just described but then there
might be some wage where people are like
you know what I have enough money and
rather than just working that extra hour
I actually might want to spend that time
with my family or or go on vacation and
in a lot of ways it's a very healthy
mindset
my personal opinion I don't think enough
people have that mindset but if that
were the case at some point when we just
get to a certain point people actually
might want to work less and so you would
have this backward bending labor supply
curve so let me write this this is a
labor supply curve
with the income effect after a certain
point income effect so it's an
interesting thing to think about is
there a certain income level above which
people say you know what I have enough
and rather than work harder I actually
might work a little bit less interesting
to think about